we're told that quadrilateral a b c d is
a rhombus and what they want us to prove
is that their diagonals are
perpendicular that a c is perpendicular
to b
d
now let's think about everything we know
about a rhombus first of all a rhombus
is a special case of a parallelogram in
a parallelogram the sides opposite sides
are parallel so that side is parallel to
that side
these two sides are parallel and in a
rhombus not only are the opposite sides
parallel it's a parallelogram but also
all of the sides have equal length so
this side is equal to this side which is
equal to that side which is equal to
that side right over there now there's
other interesting things we know about
the diagonals of a parallelogram which
we know all rhombi are parallelograms
the the other way around is not
necessarily true we know that for any
parallelogram and a rhombus is a
parallelogram that the diagonals bisect
each other so for example let me label
this point in the center let me label it
point e we know that ae we know that ae
is going to be equal to ec i'll put two
slashes right over there and we also
know that eb
we also know that eb is going to be
equal to
ed
so this is all of what we know when
someone just says that a b c d is a
rhombus based on other things that we've
proven to ourselves
now we need to prove that ac is
perpendicular to bd so an interesting
way to prove it and you can kind of look
at it just by eyeballing is if we can
show that this triangle is is congruent
to this triangle and that these two
angles right over here correspond to
each other then they have to be the same
and they'll be supplementary and then
they'll be 90 degrees so let's just
prove it to ourselves so the first thing
we see is we have a side
a side and a side a side a side and a
side so we can see the triangle let me
write here triangle let me just in a new
color
we see
that triangle
triangle a
b e
is congruent to triangle c b e
c b e
and we know that by side side side
congruency
we have a side a side to the side a side
a side and a side and then once we know
that we know that all the corresponding
angles are congruent in particular we
know that a e b
we know that angle a
e b
angle a e b is going to be congruent
to angle so a e b to c e b c e b to
angle c e b
because they are corresponding angles
of
congruent
corresponding angles of congruent
triangles
so this angle right over here is going
to be equal to that angle over there and
we also know that they are supplementary
and so
if they're both supplementary so we also
know
also
and let me write it this way they're
congruent and they are supplementary
supplementary
so we have these two are going to have
the same measure and they need to add up
to 180 degrees so if i have two things
that are the same thing and they add up
to 180 degrees what does that tell me so
that tells me that
angle
the measure of angle a
eb
is equal to the measure of angle c eb
which is equal to which must be equal to
90 degrees they're the same measure and
they are supplementary so this is a
right angle and then this is a right
angle and obviously if this is a right
angle this angle down here is a vertical
angle that's going to be a right angle
if this is a right angle this over here
is going to be a vertical angle and you
see the diagonals intersect at a 90
degree angle so we've just proved so
this is interesting in parallelogram the
diagonals bisect each other
for a rhombus where all the sides are
equal we've shown that not only do they
bisect each other but they're
perpendicular bisectors of each other